hello believe nation today we're going
to talk about how you can handle
bullying rule number one is my personal
favorite and I'd love to know which one
you guys like the best as always guys as
you're watching the clips if you hear
somebody say something that really
resonates with you please leave it in
the comments below and put quotes around
that so other people can be inspired as
well also when you write it down it's
much more likely to stick with yourself
to enjoy
[Music]
I've become an expert on this because I
was one of those big bullies and most
people wouldn't think of that about me
cuz I'm six seven but I was actually
always the smallest kid in my class part
of what kept me going was a vision in my
mind that said they made this to me
today but someday you know my life will
be more I won't be the person that
people verbally or physically abused and
and I remember being in high school
envisioning some day I was gonna be
coming to the successful person and I
was gonna make a difference and and I
become you know financially successful
was the fact that we had no money was
one of things that was bullied about
most and I never I find in a couple
these bullies annuals at the end of the
year I got all their annuals I wrote
these horrible things I became the bully
right they didn't know what I wrote
these horrible things saying someday
you'll be a truck driver and I'll be
rich and famous and you'll be there
wishing you're me and treated me better
and so I remember I went to my 10-year
high school reunion I talked to my mom
and my mom has not been much of a coach
in my life quite frankly but that day
she was really interesting she said
what's going on I said I'm going on my
10-year high school reunion and I'm just
want to say hello I'm driving the way up
and she goes honey I can hear something
in your voice what is it I said nothing
and what it was is when I was going up
there I remembered what it was like ten
years before when I felt so alone when I
felt totally an outsider when I felt I
feared for was gonna happen to me
physically or at least being harassed
and and I felt you know it's just so
different outside and alone and she said
honey she said I didn't tell her any of
that and she said I mean you were always
the outsider you were always the loner
and she goes look with being different
got you she goes now how many people are
in high school and I said I don't know
mm she goes 5,000 people show up to hear
you speak she said you know for one
weekend she said look what that's done
and that's why I try to tell young
people that are going through it is
again it's not waste our dance where you
end up some of the toughest experiences
life will give you drive if you don't
let it destroy you if you realize that
this person who's a bully is often a
bully because they're massively insecure
and just go this is temporary and get
yourself with a peer group of people who
respect you who love you appreciate you
who you appreciate my love
spend more of your time there you'll
find yourself if you're filled up by you
the rest of your life you can handle the
challenges there if it gets physical
then you got to go to some authority
that can help stop that situation if you
can't protect yourself throwing up Asian
American trying to play basketball is
really tough at times sometimes people
make fun of me and they would just say
you know oh you're Yao Ming you know
it's not that bad
sometimes they'd get a little worse they
would say oh you're Chinese import or go
back to China or can you see the
scoreboard with your eyes and then
sometimes it got really ridiculous you
know people will call me just [ __ ] or
[ __ ] or you know just racist terms like
that and I remember one time I got
really upset kind of lost control and
responded really negatively and my coach
kind of told me told me after the game
he said Jeremy you know and people say
that to you they're just trying to get
in your head and and honestly the best
thing to do is to take that negative
energy and turn into positive energy
fuel yourself motivate yourself with
that don't react in anger and so my you
know my lesson that I learned and if
there's anything I could pass some of
you guys is a lot of times bullies like
to bully other people because of certain
insecurities they have themselves and so
don't let somebody else tell you who you
are or what you can or can't do
definitely look inside yourself have
confidence in yourself believe in
yourself and understand what makes you
such a unique and special person
everybody has different and really cool
characteristic skills talents and so
never lose sight of that and just always
stay positive and hopefully one day
you'll take a look back at these
experiences and realize hey you know me
getting bullied or me having to go
through these experiences only made me
stronger one of the biggest pieces of
advice I've ever gotten in my life was
from my mom you know when I was a little
kid there was a kid
it was bugging me you know in school and
she said okay I'm gonna tell you what to
do she said the kids bugging you he puts
his hands on you
you pick up the nearest rock or whatever
you can get your hands on and you lay
him out
then I did and I felt better and it
worked so for me you know that that was
a great lesson because someone had
invaded by my space invaded my being you
know and I was doing something against
me that I didn't want to be done so I
took control the situation and I ran
with it and and many years later after
being you know turned into a product you
know by a very huge corporation that had
their hands all over me and I I couldn't
escape it
you know I promised myself that I would
continue to move forward and do my best
not to compromise in any way whatsoever
you know not not allow anyone to put
their hands on me and affect me in that
way so that's the best advice I think I
could give is just to keep moving
forward and don't don't give a [ __ ] what
anybody thinks you know just keep moving
forward and do what you have to do for
you you know I work in a business where
some people are a little bit arrogant
and you know maybe they're having a bad
day and you know I've seen this thing
kind of happened where you know you're
on a film set and someone seems to be in
a really bad mood and they're treating
people pretty badly and and generally
you can see that they're treating like
an extra badly or standing badly or
cameraman badly and no one ever
confronts them and I'm a big confronter
I will generally call a meeting into my
trailer with a producer with either the
person who's causing what I think is
unnecessary tension and disruption or
being particularly mean and I will say
look I come here every day to try to be
a part of creating an environment where
we all can do our best work
this behavior isn't gonna fly and what I
often find is that it's it's when you
confront someone who is behaving in that
kind of bullying fashion that they're
really stunned because normally they can
get away with it it's because everyone's
just like you talked to Sanne and
everyone sort of whispering and sneaking
around instead of walking up to that
person and saying what is your problem
what is your problem because your
problem is becoming our problem and in
fact we were having a really good time
until you entered the scene and created
an environment that was unpleasant
disruptive and unnecessary and you know
what it's not gonna make anyone work any
faster or any better the ways in which
you get people to work faster and better
is to treat them as equals and to treat
them as people who care about their work
and you care about your work and you
know it's only when people come together
that you can accomplish something if
you've got somebody that's bullying you
like both of you got jumped on you took
steps you reported you said the right
things you did the right things and you
still got attacked right is that fair no
way it's fair when you go to somebody in
authority and you tell them what's going
on that's not tattling you did the right
things Lilly you did right things you
still got attacked the question is what
do you do when that unfair thing happens
to you do you let that define you or you
can say well wait a minute I gotta be my
own best friend here I have the power to
choose how I feel about this I'm not
going to be embarrassed I'm not going to
be traumatized for the rest of my life
behaviors have a beginning and an end
you two got attacked lasted a few
minutes right how long has it been over
a year few months and you're still
affected by it today right you have not
given yourself permission to get past it
you've not given yourself permission to
say I encountered some sick people some
small people some petty people some
people I want you to change choices
you're already choosing how you feel
about it if this is brought up to you
what you gonna say about it
aren't you that girl I got beat up on
the tape yeah it was one of the worst
times of my life did you have a question
about it oh you know what's gonna happen
I'm gonna go oh now I guess I don't this
isn't something where time heals all
wounds time heals nothing it's what you
do with that time okay what I want you
to do is five years so now I want you to
look back and say that event became the
springboard for me being tough focused
and able to help other people move along
bullies prey on the weak to feed their
own insecurities they can't do anything
amazing themselves they don't want to
get into the arena and follow their
dreams and so what they need to do is
pull everybody down to their level if
somebody's here and somebody's up here
and you want to get closer
it's either bring the people up with you
or try to tear the other people down and
that's what bullies do and what they
crave is your response
they crave you reacting to this what
they want they want to get under your
skin they want you to feel that you're
now at their level they want to drag you
back down to where they are they want to
fight in the mud and so the solution is
don't give it to them again they want to
pull you down to feed their own
insecurities and if they don't get it
from you they're gonna get it from
somebody else and if you don't give it
to them if you don't react if you don't
yell and scream or cry or get upset
they're gonna go somewhere else they're
gonna leave you alone so stop reacting
this at the start maybe harder to
actually do it at the say right it's a
simple easy solution doesn't mean it's
actually easy to do but reminding
yourself before even you go into a
situation will make it easier for you so
if you know that there's this person
who's always bullying you and you have a
meeting with them coming up remind
yourself of it remind yourself that I'm
not going to react like this person's
opinion doesn't matter I'm not gonna let
them trigger me reminding yourself of
that before the meeting and going in
will make it easier for you to get the
desired outcome that you want and if you
do that consistently they're gonna
realize how this person doesn't care
anymore this person isn't triggered by
me anymore huh I'm not getting what I
need anymore from that person I'm not
feeding my own insecurities anymore from
that person I'm gonna go somewhere else
pick on somebody else that's what
bullies do I would strongly encourage
you to stop living your life in the
rearview mirror people ripoff my content
as an example all the time people will
post things that I'm putting up on
YouTube on their channel with credit
with no credit they're trying to do
exactly what I'm doing
I don't care people write to me all the
time like hey this person took your
video and posted them on their channel
you're not gonna do better at being me
then I will be at being me it's just not
gonna happen and I can either choose to
spend all of my time focusing on these
people and just defending what I have as
opposed to going out and getting more
I'm not concerned with somebody trying
to be the next Evan Carmichael because
you can't but you could be a better you
than I could be that's where you need to
focus your energy and so I don't spend
my time focus in the rear view mirror I
don't care about taking down those
videos or taking down those channels
what I care about is the mission that
I'm on and helping you guys and making
more new amazing awesome videos and so
if you're spending your time worrying
about bullies and dealing with bullies
and reacting the bullies then you're not
spending your time focusing on big
things and you can do to grow you're
spending your life in your rear view
mirror instead of driving forward so
stop spending your time in your rear
view mirror
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Nina asked me to
so if there's a topic you like me to
cover in the next edition of believe
life leave it down in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do I'd also love
to know what did you think about this
video what did you learn from this video
that you can apply immediately to your
life or to your business how do you
handle bullies that maybe we missed a
point that you can share you can
contribute back to believe nation and
share some knowledge as well leave it
down in the comments below I'm gonna
join in the discussion finally I want to
give a quick shout out to Matt McGill
Matt thank you so much for picking up a
copy of my book your one word and for
reading it and tweeting it out I really
appreciate the love and the support man
so thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one where it is
much love have an amazing day and I'll
see you soon
there's no question that individuals who
are quote bystanders have more power
than they realize because most bullying
is going on for the joy of that person
getting attention it's a sense of power
if nobody notices them getting power
they don't feel a lot you know and
there's some people are bullying
individual just by themselves but it's
really rare it's usually a pack
mentality and you'd like to be bigger
than that person you don't pick a fight
for that person all you have to do is
you and two or three other people just
go this is not cool
or listen we're gonna call somebody this
is dig this up some other time anything
that you do that just breaks the pattern
even for a moment that's all it takes
cuz people get in state a bully isn't
always a bully every moment their life
there you can beat somebody's a bully in
another environment they could be a
really cool kid but when there's a state
of being a bully it feeds on itself so
all it takes is a little pattern that
happened you know a lot of people afraid
although they're gonna come attack me
they might threaten you but you're not
really their focus that's not really
what it is so by the way it happens with
adults happens in a different way it
happens by you know rumors and things of
that nature it certainly happens to
celebrities I have a lot of celebrity
friends and clients and you know I'll be
at a party and somebody will say
something I'm you know in the
entertainment business especially about
this person and I'll just say you know
what I watch other people around I say
to other people are friends not say a
word I'll step up and say you know why
that is total BS you know that's BS I
know this person they're my friend what
you're saying is just completely made-up
there's no truth to us or why would you
do that it'll you put the Bern back in
that direction it's really rapid off
things change because other people look
around you know when I tell people's
don't tolerate behavior you get what you
tolerate don't tolerate behavior from
other things that you personally would
not want for yourself
and so it even if you're not the one
being bullied don't tolerate step up now
we cannot tolerate it by the power of
the third side there's person attacking
does a person who's being attacked and
there's the third side the third side
can surround it and change it in two
seconds and I say lead the third side
for a long time people we're talking
about bullying and that was a big hot
topic and I think sometimes you can
forget that you could be your own bully
in some way it's like you are the person
that is standing in the way of your
success whether it's professionally or
personally
honestly that was the case for me I was
having a great professional street but
personally I was really immature and so
I had to balance them out finally I had
enough and I said hey you need to speak
up for yourself if you're not happy with
something you change it you know change
it make yourself better every single day
so I went to a lot of therapy and I I
guess I put it in the way of like you're
gonna hear me roar finally you're I'm
gonna be able to speak up for myself